hello everyone and welcome back to the
second round of the tata steel chess
tournament 2021 we are continuing uh
with alexander doncico versus fabiano
corona the first game that ended
and it ended uh very abruptly as you'll
see uh
and it's always very interesting when
these young and up upcoming
grandmasters face the absolute top tier
ones like we like we
uh we've already seen today in the game
uh nigeria versus sari antari
uh but yeah without further ado let's
check it out it's it's quite
the game uh so dunchenko with the white
pieces opens with
d4 and we have d5 from fabi c uh
c4 and c6 a fabi goes for the slav
defense
knight to f3 and now knight to f6 with
e3
and bishop to f5 so this is all very
very standard stuff knight to c3 and e6
now the bishop has been developed and
now you can close close the gates as we
often say
uh knights the h4 now challenging that
bishop here
bishop to e4 not going for g6 right away
but rather forcing whites to
somewhat weaken his position by playing
f3
so f3 uh bishop back to g6 and now
well you could go for queen b3 and black
will reply for example queen to b6
here we have just bishop to b2 and it's
a very rare move
but it's not the first time fabi
encounters it but we're going to get
back to that we have bishop to e7 black
just continues development
and now we have a trade here captures
captures and the queen the c2
uh we have knight beat to d7 and here
are queen side castles from donchenko
uh and uh the reason i said that this is
not the first
time fabi sees this move is because fabi
already had this
uh position in the candidates tournament
this year
well in 2020 in yekaterinburg against
none other than anish giri
and giri uh well
the game ended in a draw but in that
game knight to b6 was played by caruana
but here we have
a6 and it is in fact caruana who uh
switches from the game that was played
in the candidates tournament which is
kind of weird often when you
prepare for someone it's usually going
to be you who will
switch switch it up but here caruana
actually shows
uh perhaps an improvement uh uh
up on his game uh against geary and
yekaterinburg so let's see what what's
happening here
uh dunchenko continues pushing on the
king's side we have g4
and now d captures on c4 bishop captures
and now b5
uh using this capture on c4 to further
expand on the queen side
we have bishop back to e2 and now at c5
trying to
open up the center here and here what
you would probably
do if it was a normal game d captures
knight captures and then the game
continues however
here uh dunchango decided to play in
great style and he decided to start by
sacrificing a pawn
so he played the d5 and uh just
for those of you who are wondering b4
doesn't work here because after d
captures an e6
b captures on c3 you're gonna capture on
f7 with
check and after king captures bishop
captures on c3 and it's just a
a terrible position to play uh for black
uh so instead after d5 uh five just
accepts the pawn sacrifice uh not with
the pawn but rather with the knight
knight captures we have knight captures
e captures and
now f4 uh continuing to push on the
king's side
and fabio of course now has to decide
how to continue does he want to
uh form some sort of a defense or does
he want to continue attacking on the
queen side
and since he already has quite a pawn
storm going on here
uh he continues pushing we have b4 uh
and uh of course the dunchenko continues
pushing e4
striking in the center uh we have d for
by fabi not eager to open up the d
file since the rook is nicely aligned
with the queen here and now
e5 so both players ignoring each other
we have knight to b6
fabi wants to take care of the c4 square
before he pushes this pawn to c4
white will not be able to capture back
twice because there's rook c8 and the
white's queen and king are on the same
file so e6
uh just continuing uh continuing to push
forward
no no one is interested in what the
other guy is doing so if you capture the
pawn here then queen captures and g6
becomes an option
so here fabi says i don't mind you can
capture on f7 i'm just going to play
queen to d5
so if you're not careful i can capture
this i can also capture on a2 so you
also have to take that into
consideration
so here dunchenko captures an f7 with
check
might even use this as a thumbnail not
not sure yet
uh king to f8 and now uh he just
continues pushing
on on the king's side here fabi could
have
uh considered uh capturing and of course
he did with the king and the queen but
it's better not to give white any open
lines as
you're the one who wants to attack on
the queen side so uh
another case of using your opponent's
pawn as a shield
we have h4 again continuing pushing on
the king side and here
just queen captures on a2 uh if you
tried something like
uh trying to defend the pawn uh you
could also you you could always try that
uh but um it's not gonna be uh
it's not gonna be any better black will
just continue pushing and
white really doesn't have any time to
time to waste so here
uh we have like we said queen captures
on a2 and now
queen captures on g6 so white is really
close to the black king here
but like we said this really works as a
shield and white doesn't really have a
way of getting through this
it will take a couple of moves but it's
a question of whether he has them
whether he has them so here quinte1
check could be met with king to d2
king to c2 and then you can start
running away so here fabi takes away the
c2 square from the white king and now
the threat is
uh not right away but quinte1 will be a
terrible threat
if this queen ever leaves the control of
the b1 square
so here if you go queen back to b1 to
try and trade queens
favi will just go back start pushing the
pawn and win the game
so instead we have bishop back to e1 by
donchenko now creating uh
an escape square for the king if check
is delivered and now fabi just uh
continues pushing here we have c4
uh even giving up the d4 pawn fabi uh
finds a brilliant
brilliant attacking resource here we
have rook captures on d4
and now knight to a4 threatening queen
captures and b2 with uh
with with a devastating attack so here
queen to b1
defending and now again it's a question
why did why did fabi trap his own queen
here why did he allow
uh whites to kind of force a queen trade
uh well maybe
in fact he didn't so uh feel free to
pause the video here
and try to find this brilliant winning
move for fabi while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting uh
such a move as it's it's really not an
easy one to find and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
uh no it's not that i'm just joking uh
it's bishop to a3
so bishop to a3 congratulations to
everyone who found it
and now the point is there really uh
there really is no good move here for
white whatever you do
is just not gonna not gonna work if you
accept the bishop
then just b2 with check is deadly and
there's not much you can do you have to
leave the defense of the the queen and
after the king was just queen captures
on b1
and you've lost the queen and you don't
have this option of bishop to be for
check and
recapturing because the king is in the
way so after this
bishop the a3 move donchenko captured
fabi's queen but now
pong captures an a2 and there is no way
for the king to prevent queening
uh because the b1 square is covered by
the pawn but dunchenko finds a very
resourceful
king to c2 now if fabi brings a queen
into the game now don chenko can give up
the bishop bishop to b4
this comes with check and after captures
he's just going to recapture the queen
on a1 but
fabi is not to be tricked like that fabi
instead plays rook to b8
and he waits with this pawn to a1 move
now covering the b4 square
and asking what do you what do you play
here well
uh the absolute most disgusting engine
like defense here for white uh
and even that isn't enough but i will
show it because it's super fun bishop to
b4 with
check first you give up the bishop you
go bishop to c4 and now okay
for the moment black cannot queen but
rook captures on b2
with check king d3 and now white is
actually threatening uh rook 28 so you
have to take care of that
bishop to e7 and now rook to e1 again
trying to bait black into going rook to
b1 to kind of go for
a queen promotion but here uh donchenko
would actually have a forced
checkmate check on the 8 bishop captures
and rook to e8 is now checkmate
but of course this is not forced fabi uh
will not go for rook to b1 here fabi
here will just play knight to c5 check
push the king away and after the king
moves king to c3 now go
just go back rook to b8 everything is
defended fabi's up material
and it's just going to be a very very
easy game to play for uh for fabi
so this is what happens even with the
absolute best most disgusting engine
like defense
but this is not what dunchenko went for
don chenko instead went for rook to d8
with check he decided to give up the
rook
uh to prevent uh white from uh from
going rook capture
from preventing black from going uh rook
captures on v2
so here fabi grabs it and now b captures
an a3
grabbing that one and now again if you
bring a queen into the game just bishop
b for check and the rook picks up the
queen
so uh fabi takes care of that he pushes
c3
and now you don't have bishop to b4
anymore
and uh well what do you play here you
have to move the bishop somewhere the
rook must cover the a1 square so here
dunchenko goes bishop to g3 but now
fabi just goes rook to d2 with check we
have king to b3
and here fabi doesn't want to part with
his knight uh he played knight to c5 but
we're going to show
that it's actually uh very interesting
if you allow black
white to capture the knight because
after captures and captures you just cut
the white king off completely and that
king is never
entering the game again also you're
threatening rook to b1
and you're going to promote the spawn so
white's only move is rook to a1
but now you have a king that's stuck
here for the rest of the game and you
have a rook here that's stuck here for
the rest of the game
not only that c2 just wins the game on
the spot there's nothing to do rook to
b1 is coming and whatever white plays
next move you're going to promote a pawn
to a queen
for example bishop f2 anything just rook
to b1
captures and c1 queen and black is of
course completely winning
uh but fabi did not go for this fight he
played knight to c5
check but he was also in this position
on move 32
uh that uh alexander donchenko resigned
to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
once the king moves or whatever you do
king captures on c3 are going to capture
on e2
and there is no counter play left black
is just up a whole rook he has a pass
pawn on a2 and that's just
that's just uh uh plenty for
uh for fabi to win this game easily so
of course
after knight to c5 check the game ended
and a great
great victory for fabi in round two but
this is what i meant
that i really really enjoyed these
tournaments where you don't just have
uh top 10 players uh like you have in
the candidates tournament because
those games are like nine out of ten are
snooze fest but here when you have
uh such up-and-coming uh grand masters
like alexander denchenko who are yeah
who are
not just willing but also eager to uh
you know
just go after the the the grandmaster
just trying to take him down then we get
a beautiful attacking games like
these ones and it's uh it's what we most
enjoy
so yeah a great game by both of them and
you know
india and fabi won but uh you know very
very creative uh
uh approach by alexander doncico so
congratulations on that as well
uh i hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would
like to thank adriano nunes
uh michael de forma greg lemke rohan
david kimura and
william gould for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the tata still
probably more games from round two
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day